- Alright, good?
- Hey there! I'm Aria.
And we're here in the San Fernando Valley,
the heart some might say,
of the adult entertainment industry
to take a look behind the scenes
at where the sausage is made
here at the Vixen offices.
- What's up?
- It's Abigail, right?
- How are you? Yes!
- Please lead the way.
- I don't know, I heard you
guys were trouble makers.
- Abigail starts our
day with a quick tour.
- So welcome to the Vixen office.
- This is an award winning studio.
- They are.
- I mean, let me look at this.
We've got Greg Lansky
"Best Cinematography",
"Best Specialty Movie- Other Genre",
"Come Inside Me",
"Best Ethnic Interracial Series",
"Best Solo Tease Performance"
for you, that's you!
- Oh, wait! I've got two of them up there.
- Is there a movie you've done
that you're very proud of
but the awards, they just snubbed it?
- I was a girl-girl
performer for three years
and I never won a
girl-girl performance scene
which I thought was a little ridiculous
because I was very, I feel
like, good at what I did.
- But you, I mean, you've won two.
- Yes.
- You're kind of like the Meryl Streep
of the porn industry.
- Wait, this looks familiar.
Oh, she looks really...
- Oh, it's you! It's Abigail!
- Oh it's me! This is what
my two awards were won for!
- You won for this?
Being able to see Abigail's film with her
was a bit of an experience.
This is, oh my!
You're saying things to him,
what are you saying to
him in here right now?
- I'm probably saying,
like, I'm going to...
(bleep)
stuff like that. Yeah.
- I will say this though,
I mean you guys didn't see it,
it looked incredible.
The cinematography was top notch.
It's like I was watching
a Terrence Malick film.
Although, I actually
knew what was going on.
Shortly after, Greg Lansky,
the man many consider
to be revolutionizing
the porn industry, arrives.
- Well today, you know,
we're going to announce
our newest Vixen Angel.
It's a pretty big event for us.
We do it every month.
I created, really, this title
and this crowning in order to celebrate
the woman of the adult industry
in a light that is not often the case
so today is all about her.
- Previous angels, including Abigail,
are now live on Instagram
to help make the announcement.
In the pink over there, that's Nicole,
she's about to be announced
as the newest Vixen Angel.
- This is the Instagram
story, live, right now.
Look at that, look at all those hearts.
The only people that every
watch my Instagram stories
are my parents.
- The newest Vixen Angel is...
Nicole Aniston!
(applause)
Yeah, come on, come on!
And we are done. Boom.
(applause)
- Now we've moved, we're
here in the South Central.
Is this South Central?
Alright, we are now here in South Central
where we are shooting
Nicole's Angel photoshoot.
It's crazy. It's very foggy
in here, can barely see.
But it's looking very, very cool
and actually been a
very exciting afternoon.
Get you covered.
Just trying to do what I can to help.
- High pressure, guys.
Lots of shots to cover,
you see what I'm saying?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
That was nice, this one.
Right there. Oh my God.
Amazing.
You look incredible.
- It's gone really well.
Long day, honestly.
It's really worth it, I mean,
it's a lot of fun.
It's something different
I've never done before
and I love the projects
that he comes up with,
the concepts, the ideas,
they all really piece
together really beautifully.
- To learn more about what's setting
Vixen apart in the industry,
I chat with Angel of the
Year, Kendra Sunderland.
- I remember when Greg wanted to make me
the very first Vixen Angel,
and I just, like, I cried.
I'm just so happy because
my whole life I've never been
a winner, I've got last place metals
for every sport possible
and so, for him to pick me to be
the very first and lead it and everything,
I was just so honored.
It was really overwhelming.
One thing that Greg really wanted to do
is just show that this
is really just artistic
and our pictures are art
and we deserve to be respected as artists
because we're more than that.
Porn doesn't just have to be,
this like cheap camera,
hotel stuff, you know?
People tell us all the time
"You don't even have a real job."
Shooting with Greg, it's
more than just a job,
it's like being a part of a project
and something way bigger than that
so I'm really glad that
he advocates for us
that what we do is art
because we get enough crap from people,
it's great to have him to remind us
that we are artists in what we do.
- Well, Greg. What a day!
- What a day, right?
- What a long day. It is
seven o'clock, wrap on time.
- Wrap on time always.
- How do you feel it went, honestly?
- I thought it went great.
Nicole was amazing.
She looked really powerful
and every one of the Vixen Angel,
we really want to celebrate
the woman of the adult industry
and show a powerful image.
So, you know, it's boxing,
it's coming out of a helicopter,
it's all kinds of fun theme.
We want to stop the preconceived notion
that anything adult is cheap.
It can be creative.
It can be artistic.
We define what we do.
We want to stop having the adult industry
being cast in the shadow.
Half people learn to question,
at least the preconceived notions
they have of the adult industry,
because when people look at us,
they see that wow, they
put in a lot of effort,
a lot of money, a lot of means
just to get fantastic shots
because that's what we're about.
We like to do things grand.
- Grand is definitely the word
I would use to sell this stuff.
- Absolutely.
- I guess my final question for you is
if I wanted to get on your list
of male talent, how do we get that?
- Sure. Right. Okay, well you know
just write me an email,
photo front and back.
- Front and back? Why
do you need a back shot?
- You always need a back shot.
- Oh, no no, you always need a back shot.